all right thank you so much and for
inviting me and I'll keep this really
really basic at the request of Ron and
Shamir so basically what I'm gonna cover
is and what a regulatory elements how we
look for them and functional assays for
them and biochemical assays for them and
I'll land in the end with one example
from our lab but a as our own requested
I'll keep it very general and I think
later on in the Simon's and when there's
gene regulatory and workshops I'll talk
more about the work that we actually do
this is again very basic and just to
make sure that everybody's online and
same page and to get to this okay so and
as geneticist we're really really good
at finding genes so if this sequence for
example was a gene we'd probably pick it
up because genes have these rules that
we know they start from ATG then the TGA
they have exons and introns and start
the AG AG T so we get to serve an A for
finding genes we're good at this but if
this sequence was a regulatory element
and it would be hard for me to figure
that out and one of the main reasons is
that we're faced with a problem that
ninety-eight percent of our genome
actually doesn't code for protein and so
we have this vast genomic space to
search for regulatory elements in
addition for genes we have this code
that we know for example CCC codes for
prolene and we also know the
consequences of nucleotide changes to
that code you change CCC to CTC protein
changes to leucine and that could lead
to some sort of phenotype but we don't
have all that for regulatory elements so
one the problem is even if I find a
regulatory Eman I don't know the code of
it I don't know what it's going to be
doing at this stage and if I find a
mutation in it a nucleotide change in it
I really don't know what it's doing on a
phenotypic level still at this stage and
a lot of the work that my lab has been
doing which I'll show later on today is
really trying to get a better
understanding of this code and and what
mutations in these regulatory elements
could lead to in terms of phenotypes and
and as you see there's still a long way
to go with that and we've also been
working on developing a lot of
high-throughput technologies to allow us
to get a better sense of this so why do
we care about these regulatory elements
well if you have nucleotide changes in
these switches that tell the genes when
to turn on when to turn off and that
could lead to differences in gene
expression and those differences could
lead to phenotypes like human variation
between people morphological differences
between species it's thought a lot of
differences between species for example
and if you compare humans to chimps
there's not a lot of differences in
protein coding sequences but the main
difference is probably due to regulatory
differences and so finding these
switches and the changes in them can
lead us to better understanding of this
happens and also human disease and
there's now more and more cases that are
coming out showing that a lot of
mutations in these regulatory elements
can lead to human disease and for
example if you look at all the
genome-wide Association studies that
have been done G was on humans for a
very variety of diseases and other
phenotypes like pharmacogenomics the
majority of them almost 90% actually hit
non-coding regions and to not hit genes
and so clearly there's a lot of human
disease that could be caused by
mutations and regulatory elements and
Noddin genes so as I mentioned what
we're going to do today is talk about
the different kinds of gene regulatory
elements how can we find them
how far away to look for them functional
assays that we and others do to test
their function later on a bit of
regulation in three-dimension 3d and an
example from our lab and this is
completely informal so really at any
point if you have a question please
don't don't hesitate to ask okay alright
so and the different kinds of gene
regulatory elements so and so promoters
I'm assuming everybody knows promoters
is there anybody okay
so here we have a gene and gene a let's
say and it has a transcription start
site right here and
of what's called a promoter that
basically turns on gene a and here I'm
showing you a mouse embryo and that was
stained and with Lexi for the expression
of a gene so this gene is expressed here
in the limbs in the developing neural
tube and in the brain here and and this
promoter you would think could drive
this expression pattern however what
people have seen is that if you inject
just the promoter and this gene you
don't get this complex expression
pattern in most cases however if you
inject a bigger chunk of DNA you start
seeing this complex expression pattern
and the reason is that they are huh so
before I jump to that I forgot to
mention so in terms of promoters also
one thing to keep in mind that there
could be alternative promoters so you
may have promoter a and promoter B for
the same gene and that could lead to
differences also in splice variants and
differences in expression so that's an
important point that I forgot to mention
and going back to promoters not being
sufficient so as I mentioned promoters
can sometimes not be sufficient and if
you inject a bigger chunk of DNA you
start getting this expression pattern
and that's because their sequences
called enhancers that tell the promoter
to turn on for example here in the limb
here in the neural tube and here in the
brain so then hand stores are sort of
the promoters of the promoter and they
basically tell this promoter to light up
in this tissue and combine these
enhancers and the promoter give you this
complex expression pattern there are
also other regulatory elements and
probably the least studied ones are
called silencers so silencers are
basically the opposite of the promoter
and they can basically silenced the
promoter and shut down this gene by
either looping or other ways and histone
modifications and so forth and one of
the reasons there's not as silences as
I'll show you later there's not really
good functional assays yet to find
silencers
there's also especially in my lab a big
argument whether silencers are just
enhancers are silenced or silencers
exist but that's another thing
insulators is another group of
regulatory elements so let's say we have
a gene
called gene B and it has an expression
right here in the eye and has a promoter
what could happen is that these
enhancers for example this limb enhancer
could start turning on this promoter
right here in the limb and now suddenly
you have a gene that shouldn't be
expressed in the limb being expressed in
the limb and so there are DNA sequences
called insulators that are here but you
can imagine them as being like a Chinese
wall and then let's China wall and then
they basically insulate and don't let
this sequence go here and turn on this
promoter it can only go here and turn on
that promoter in a sense that's very
sort of simplifying it but that's sort
of the idea of insulators are all of
these clear for everybody since I'm
gonna talk about again there's no such
thing no so definitely there are essays
and I'll show you later on how people
and basically find promoters it's it's
pretty quite simple where you put a
sequence that you think as a promoter
and Thrones of a reporter gene and you
see if it lights up and where does it
light up so yeah definitely and a lot of
people do that yeah
definitely it's a great question so yeah
enhancers can be located five-prime they
can be three prime to the gene they can
be even on another chromosome so there's
a nice example for the h enhancer which
is an olfactory receptor and answer
that's actually on another chromosome
binds to another chromosome and enhances
so yeah they could definitely be
anywhere and in terms of how far away to
look for enhancer is insists we'll talk
a little bit more later on also any
other questions before I continue all
right so this is clear since I'm gonna
talk about these regulatory elements in
particular about enhancers okay so these
are serve the different flavors of
regulatory elements I guess going back I
think and we still really don't have a
great understanding and I think there's
a lot of different regulatory elements I
think there's a lot of different types
of enhancers and I think they're
hopefully the field will move forward in
the years to come but I think you know
enhancer is a very big general term a
sort of like a car but there are very
different kinds of cars and so I think
there's a lot more work to do to define
enhancers and also these other
regulatory elements and and hopefully
we'll see a lot of that in the future
but for now I'm just using a general
term enhancer silencer insulator
promoter so how can we find these
regulatory elements and and what can we
do to find them and so there's quite a
lot of different ways to find them and
I'll talk just about a few of them sort
of the more common ones and one it's
thought that transcription factors bind
to these regulatory elements and
activate them or silenced them and so
forth so you can look just on the
sequence level at transcription factor
binding sites which we'll talk about
another is comparative genomics
comparing genomes in evolution and
another is chip and there are other
technologies but chip is probably the
most commonly used so I'll talk a bit
about chip and then also D and not seek
and attack sequence is now quite widely
used also so start with transcription
factor binding sites and this is pretty
simplified and the talk after me will be
a lot about transcription factor binding
sites and motif so I'm really gonna keep
it simple so and here we have
let's say we have an enhancer and here
this alien spaceship is a transcription
factor that basically binds to this
sequence and so if we scan for example
the genome for the sequence we can try
and find that we know this transcription
factor it likes to bind to we can find
regions in the genome that could be
regulatory elements however it's not
that simple as as you'll probably see
also in the talk after me because
sometimes this transcription factor
likes to bind also to this sequence
which is a bit different but has a name
here or this sequence which is a bit
different and so what people have done
different transcription factor binding
sites is develops what's called position
weight metrics which again I'm sure you
all know but just in case so if we look
at the position weight metrics for
example for this position most of the
time you see an a so let's say 60% and
40% of the time you see a T in this
position that the transcription factor
likes to bind to second position T TAA
so you see eighty percent twenty percent
and so on and so forth so these are
called
position weight metrics where you can
sort of give a transcription factor
binding site estimate of where it'll
bind and how it will bind at what
percentage this is clear for everybody
okay
another way to look at these is logo
plots and which is a very nice graphical
way where basically the size of the
letter gives you the size of the binding
so for example here you have in a that's
much higher than a T because 60% of the
time you get a T here 80% of the time
certain yeah 60 percent with time you
get an A sorry and here 80 percent of
the time you get a T so you'd get a very
large T versus a very small a and so
forth so these are the logo plots which
would be a similar way to look at this
okay so there's a lot of transcription
factor binding site programs this is
just a few this is a bit old and that
you can use to find these and and I
won't bore you too much this within the
slides and again the next stop will be a
lot on the motif searches and so one
thing one way you can think about is you
look at the sequence you look for
transcription factor binding sites and
you can speculate that a TF might bind
there however the problem is that for
example her a six base pair sequence
there could be a lot of places to look
for
and so you really need to have improved
ways to finding these and I'll show you
one example of how people improve this
so and another way is to find these
regulatory elements by using comparative
genomics and that's been quite used
extensively until about and say five
seven years ago before chip really
kicked in and chip seek which we'll talk
about later on but it's still being used
and still a nice way to find potential
regulatory elements and so the idea here
is that you just take advantage of
evolution so for example here if we
compare a non-coding sequence not a gene
between human Mouse chicken and fish we
can look for regions that have been
conserved throughout evolution for
example this region right here
and if it concern is conserved you think
that it might have some kind of function
and that function could be being a
regulatory element either enhancer
promoter insulator silencer or so forth
so you can take advantage of comparative
genomics to try and find regions that
could be functional in the genome and
this is another website that is quite
easy to use that I recommend if you want
to do comparative genomics they see our
browser and there's also the UCSC genome
browser that allows you to use this also
the ECR browser is really web-based and
very easy to use what it does here for
example is it's comparing human to and
to fish frog chicken opossum mouse and
dog each one of these tracks basically
is a comparison to one of them and if
you get a peak that means that that
sequence here is an exon for example you
can see that that sequence is conserved
all the way from humans and to fish in
this position and that's usually a lot
of how comparative genomic tracks are
used also in the UCSC genome browser and
others is basically giving you a peak of
conservation show you that it's
conserved and going back to the
transcription factor binding a problem
as I said six base pairs can be quite
common in the human genome for example
seven hundred and thirty four thousand
times and so how do you make sense of
what could be functional and what can be
not so one way is
to use conservation that I just showed
you for example if we compare umand
Emmaus and we have that same sequence
here and here this one is based on
conservation since it's not conserved
you can speculate it's less likely to be
a functional transcription factor of
this one it's more likely to be a
functional transcription factor so using
comparative genomics in a sense can
allow you also to take motifs and think
which ones are more functional and which
aren't and of course there is many other
ways to sort of filter and screen
through motifs and so forth clear so far
okay so one nice way and that's another
reason for showing this program you see
our browser to do this is and and any
one of these Peaks if you click on the
peak here that will open up the and
window here that shows you the
conservation and the comparison in this
case between frog and humans so you can
see that this sequence is conserved over
two hundred and twenty five base pairs
seventy-two percent and and another nice
thing is when you click here on conserve
transcription factors it takes you to a
program called our Vista that looks at
transcription factor binding sites in
combination with conservation so for
example you can see that this sequence
is conserved and here you have a lot of
transcription factor binding sites in
the conserved sequence and so you would
speculate that they're probably
functional and that will help you sort
of narrow down the regions of importance
and the regions of function where that
is there so far okay so comparative
genomics can also be used just to
annotate and new genomes and so forth
and this is sort of a joke I always show
so let's say I walked down in Berkeley
and I found these alien here that is
very green and basically I want to
figure out why it's green I can you know
ride it up and make DNA and then I
sequence it and I find that the alien
DNA matches jellyfish GFP and so using
comparative genomics can also really
assign other functions like you know
protein function and also other things
and so it's quite a useful tool also
nowadays where a lot of people are using
a chip seek and other biochemical
technologies I think to find function
and define
and better understanding of what things
are doing both regulatory and also
coding so comparative genomics as I
mentioned is probably the sequent the
technique that's most highly used now
for and gene regulatory finding and the
reason that is is this isn't sort of a
nice experiment with people looked at
how they could predict enhancers based
on various techniques so if we look at
comparative genomics you have a twenty
to fifty percent chance of finding
something that's an enhancer if you add
to its transcription factor binding
sites like I showed you before it gives
you about a 50 to 60 percent chance so
it's a good increase but for example
huge chips seek for a P 300 which we'll
talk about in a minute what it is it's a
good mark for enhancers you really
increase your success rate in finding
functional enhancers to 87% as you can
see here and same in terms of finding
tissue specificity if you want to know
if that enhancer for example is a
enhancer in the brain and if you use
comparative genomics that's going to be
hard to do transcription factor binding
sites might help you because you may
know that there's some transcription
factors that are brain specific that
bind in the brain and activate things in
the brain so that can increase it at 50
percent but if you use chip seek 84
percent so again this clearly search
shows the advantage of chips seek and
being much more accurate in finding
regulatory elements and this is I think
a bit of an inflation I say it's
probably a bit lower than this and
actually finding functional sequences
but still does much much better than
these guys which are also been inflated
I see in this or example here
what fraction is a true positive right
so this could miss still alone yeah yeah
so in all of these I think when you test
them you know a lot of them are not
enhancers in the sense that you have a
lot of false positives and that being
said it also depends on when and how you
test it and and yeah so in this article
that I'm source fighting that I'll show
later on and they had a great success
rate but and you know I know how random
their their choice was and you know and
usually as a biologist you choose near
genes that you're very interested in
know that have an important function in
there if you choose so but I what I do
agree with this a lot is it definitely
gives you a better success rate than
these techniques and I think combining
all of them and there is now a lot of
tools like an enhancer finder from Katie
Polar's lab and others that if you
combine all of these things together
with a lot of other things I think can
really improve your both your chip seek
Peaks predictions and so forth you still
have a lot of work to do that completely
so what is chip seek so chip seek
basically and what you do is you take
your tissue or your cell line of
interest and you use formaldehyde and
what formaldehyde does is basically
makes the DNA binding proteins the
transcription factors or anything that
binds to DNA gets stuck on the DNA so
now you have basically DNA with
everything that binds to its are stuck
on the DNA and then you chop the DNA to
smaller pieces so you can later on be
able to sequence it and so now you have
small pieces of DNA with for example the
spread transcription factor bound to the
DNA or these blue transcription factors
bound to the DNA and then the trick is
used an antibody that is specific to
that transcription factor that you're
interested in so let's say I was
interested in this red transcription
factor I use an antibody for it and that
way I can and I put this antibody on a
column for example so that way just the
DNA pieces that have this red
transcription factor get captured well
for example this piece that doesn't have
the red transcription factor it gets
washed out and so now I have all the DNA
sequences where this transcription
factor binds to and now basically what I
want to do is
sequence those DNA pieces to see where
that transcription factor and binds to
and so for that I have to reverse the
cross links I have to remove the DNA
binding proteins from the DNA so that's
sort of the next step and then basically
I can figure out what are these DNA
sequences where this protein this
transcription factor binds to so the way
to figure it out one is you can just do
qpcr on one region so you can design
primers let's say on this region here
and here and you want to see if you get
enrichment if you get a PCR product
that's much stronger in your chip versus
your control and the control is usually
doing exactly the same thing but not
having an antibody so you don't have an
antibody you shouldn't be enriching for
a certain sequence and so with the
antibody you should be enriching for it
so if you do a PCR for this where you
have the antibody versus one that you
don't have any antibody and you're not
enriching for these sequences you also
have these sequences in there and so
forth you should see a much stronger PCR
band or measured by Q PCR for those that
have the antibody that clear for
everybody okay so that's why qpcr
another way that people used to do this
is by chip you take your DNA and you
throw it on an array and that covers the
genome and you see what sequences get
enriched but nowadays with sequencing
everybody is just taking all of this
throwing it on the sequencer and you
basically get all the sequences in the
genome where this antibody binds to and
that's usually the standard and almost
cost as much as doing now a few PCR so
and it's much more widely used and again
you get a genome-wide sort of yeah view
of where this transcription factor binds
to is that clear so talk a lot about
chip seek later on yeah
so at the end so when you have the DNA
and you can do a qpcr so let's say
you're interested in this region let's
say region a so you can design primers
that will PCR this region a and
technically if you if your chip worked
and you've enriched for this region you
should get much higher sort of if you
think about a band you must much get a
good much higher band then if you don't
enrich for it then you don't have an
antibody and you're getting all possible
sequences that clear the sequence size
yeah so usually it's a you design it to
be about 250 base pairs between 250 to
500 base pairs for libraries for
Illumina libraries yeah so you chop the
DNA before with sonicator usually that's
what's routinely used or there's an
enzymes that you can use but people
usually use a sonicator where it you so
one of the first things when we do a
chip in the lab in a certain tissue or
cell is we take the cells and we cross
link them and then we actually sonic ate
them at different conditions and we want
to figure out which condition gives us
sowe're the size that we want which is
on average 250 base pairs
so that's a great business with
transcription factors and it's not a you
so you'd get about a P it's what's
called a peek which we'll show you later
on you get a peek which is about two
hundred and fifty base pairs to three
hundred base pairs out I say three
hundred base beverage so you don't
really know where in that three hundred
base period vines and there are other
ways which I won't talk about today but
have you talked later that is chip XO
which is a technique that really gives
you it's a way to basically really
figure out where it binds it's a bit
more complicated to do but you can
really get a sense of where that
transcription factor binding is taking
place but usually people just do
standard chip where you get these three
hundred base pair peak and you can
speculate where it binds there another
thing you can use this transcription
factor binding site programs to see if
you're getting for example if you know
what it binds to where that would be but
it gives you a speculation that it binds
there it doesn't necessary tell you
exactly where it binds and then I'll
talk a little bit more about histone
marks where they're you're really
getting gigantic Peaks 2kb Peaks or so
forth which I'll talking about thousand
any other questions on on chip okay so
then what antibodies do people use for
finding these regulatory elements and
there's quite a lot of different
antibodies that people use in it to much
to talk about I'll just talk about the
main ones today so one simple one just
like I've showed you before is you can
use an antibody for a transcription
factor in that way you find all the
regions in the genome where this
transcription factor binds to and that's
crazy standard the problem with this is
and that chip really depends on the
quality of your antibodies probably the
number one sort of the determining thing
on how good your chip works and so if
transcription factors antibodies
sometimes aren't as good a lot of
antibodies have been done for proteins
for other things like Western blots or
other things that people use and
sometimes it doesn't necessarily mean
that the antibody is going to be good
for your chip your antibody basically
has to pick up your transcription factor
when it's binding to the DNA and the
conformation of the protein can be
different and so forth
so and chip for transcription factors
could be sometimes problematic in
particular for the TF and if you ever
want to do a chip TF it's worth seeing
if somebody's done it before for that
transcription factor and if they've done
it and it worked for them that's
probably the antibody that you want to
use for starters to see if it works and
one example from our lab we had a
protein that we wanted to do TF for and
nobody's done it before so basically
what we've done is we've ordered four
different antibodies did the chip seek
and one of them works so a lot of times
it's sorta hiddenness there and you can
do some experiments to see if the
antibody works well or not but I wish
ship C getting so easy and cheaper and
in the end sort of the your end result
is chip seek for us it was just simpler
to do for chip six and see which one
works and which one doesn't it's
definitely a tough thing in terms of
chip is the antibody so other antibodies
are really widely used one because
they're they work really really well for
chip and two they they give you sort of
a global picture if we go back here all
this will give us is where that specific
TF that we're interested in binds to
which is great if you're interested in
that transcription factor but if you're
interested more in a global view like
where are all the enhancers where all
the insulators or so forth there are
under antibodies that you can use there
are really commonly used for histones so
as you know and histones are and
basically DNA is wrapped up in histones
right here and there's a four different
histone and proteins and then sort of
the histone one that starts like a
ziplock seals up here the and DNA and
histones have a variance also so for
example h-2a here that makes up this
ball has a variant called h2 AZ which
can be used as a there's antibodies that
are really good for it and h2 AZ has
been shown to be a mark for active
regions like promoters and answers and
so forth so that's one example but
probably the most commonly used one is
histone tails so histones have tails
like you can see here
and the histone tails have various
modifications on their and tails like
exhalation methylation ubiquitination
simulation force correlation and based
on the notifications on the tails that
can tell you if some region is for
example active or silenced is that the
gene is it a promoter or is it an
insulator and so forth so a lot of these
marks here on the tails of the histones
can be used for chip and the advantage
as I said is gives you a global view you
can find all the enhancers all the
promoters and not just the ones that
your transcription factor binds to and
another advantage is that the antibodies
for these tails are really very very
good and so for chip it usually works
very nicely with them so this is just an
example of the nomenclature for this so
for example here we have histone h3 and
it has this tail right here that you can
see here and you can see here these are
all the different modifications that you
can have you can also have cleavage of
this tail which I won't talk about but
in terms of the noumic and some of these
are can be activated some can be
repressed and so forth based on the sort
of where you have the position and what
you have on the tail so in terms of
nomenclature for example this is
position number 3 1 2 1 2
well I guess it sorry number 4 so this
is histone h3 position number 4 and this
is a lysine so at position number 4 of
lysine so h3k4 lysine and you have a
methylation here and so this would be
called h3k4 methylation if it's right
here for example this is h3 this is
lysine 18 and you have an assimilation
here so this would be called a 3k 18
oscillation and you can have one methyl
group here you can have three methyl
groups here so this would be called a
streak k4 trimethylation this one will
be called h3k4 monomethylation so this
is just to make sure we're all in line
with all the nomenclature for this is
this clear for everybody so I'll use
this a lot later on
okay so that's how people basically call
these modifications and as I said there
are various antibodies for all these
different modifications that can really
allow us to find serve in a genome-wide
manner a lot of these regulatory
elements and this is a nice slide from
this article that I like that shows all
the different modifications for the
different histones as any as you can see
yeah
so yeah so it's been clear for a lot of
work from other people that have mapped
these and and figured them out some
recently some way back so people know
usually if you have and we'll talk a bit
a little bit about with which mark does
what but there's been a lot of work of
basically doing a lot of chips so you
can seeing where these things fall in
the genome do they fall on promoters or
dead following answers and pass work on
a single basis awesome so yeah and some
of them are not as well known actually
still do things I think some of them
will be very interesting to look and
some tissues also have unique marks ale
factory receptors going back to that
have actually kind of unique silencing
marks that other tissues so have not
been found to have so the easiest is to
do some chip for example and find all
the regions in the genome and then align
them and let's say you align them and
you see they all fall near and introns
just you know throwing it so you would
think maybe it's a mark for introns or
something like that so yeah that's
that's probably the easiest way to do
nowadays in the past it was much more
statistic and so here you can see sort
of a list of all the different
modifications this is each histone each
modification that it has and sort of
what it tells you that it's sort of
acting and marking in the genome and so
and this is sort of another code that
you can think about in terms of the DNA
and one that's especially for chip seek
and regulatory elements is very useful
for people so what antibodies do we use
for each and mark that I just showed you
or for each sort of regulatory element
so for genes for example if I want to
find a gene that's active and
transcribed and I can use an antibody
for h3 so this is histone 3 lysine 36
trimethylation it's with three
methylation groups on histone three lies
in 36 so usually transcribed genes would
have this mark on the tail and so if I
use an antibody and chip for this I can
easily find all the transcribed genes in
the genome similar
to RNA seek for example if you all know
I can find using this all the genes that
are actively being transcribed so that
could be a great mark for that clear
alright so for promoters and there's
quite a few different and things that we
could use so h3k4 so let's start with
this one so RNA polymerase it binds to
the right near the promoter and starts
and basically transcribing and there's
an antibody for RNA polymerase that
people use to find all the transcribed
genes and the active promoters and so
that's a simple one and that's more of a
serve like a protein on a histone mark
but in terms of histone mark so people
have seen is that in the promoter
usually get a lot more of h3k4
trimethylation and less h3k4
monomethylation so depletion so if you
see sequences where you have a lot of
page 3 k4 so you have three methyl
groups instead of one those are more
likely to be promoters and that's a one
way to find promoters other marks for
promoters are h3k9 isolation and h3k27
trimethylation and there are there's and
also the people use going back to
enhancers so enhancers and there's quite
a few marks and like these listed here
and going back to this mark where you
have a lot of h3k4 trimethylation versus
mono enhancers are the opposite you
usually get a lot of more mono and less
tri so if you find a sequence where you
have a lot more mono let's try that it's
probably an enhancer if you find the
sequence has more try less farno that's
probably a promoter and probably the one
that's most used is h3k27 acetylation
and the reason is that what people have
seen is that this mark is actually
really good for active enhancers so in
answers are really active at that time
point while h3k4 monomethylation but
this one really gives you the active
ones yeah
some kind of try yeah yeah I don't yeah
so so this one basically has more
methylation which changes something in
the histone in terms of its
accessibility I guess I'm terrible at
this so I I don't know what is sort of
the biochemical reason for this and but
there is definitely probably a
biochemical reason why having two methyl
groups makes this sort of more than
promoter and more more open more active
might be more active and this needs to
be a bit less active or less open I but
I'm yeah yeah
so they're both activating the genes
though a promoter can be so this this
finds active promoters it doesn't find
all promoters it will find you active
promoters a promoter can also be very
silenced and then you wouldn't find you
would find probably a very different
mark here and this mark that I just
mentioned h3 case when he said in this
inactive mark that's probably the most
widely used now for enhancers you also
see it a lot of times on promoters and
you can use it also for active promoters
so there's a lot of crosstalk between
these also
any other questions on this yeah
so the thought is that poison serve it's
it's ready it's on the starting line but
no gun is being sounded yet and then the
active is it's already active and
working and so forth so that sort of
thing
metaphor for that and it's it's been
seen that love enhancers are poised
they're usually ready but something has
to activate them to make them active and
other ones I mentioned h2 a-z and the
other one that's used a lot for
enhancers is p300 and which I'll talk
about and give you an example for so
p300 is a histone acetyl transferase so
basically what it does is it throws at
settle groups on and basically on
histone @h and so that opens up
basically the region and makes it more
active and what people have seen that it
definitely tends to co-localize with
enhancers both poison and active and I
mentioned before in terms of p300 and I
gave you that example of 85% are a to a
certain tissue and eighty percent of
beginning where I showed you that and
enhancers Sarris chipsy can be better
for finding enhancers versus comparative
genomics or comparative genomic NTS this
is from this article from my former lab
up here in the Berkeley Lab where they
used P 300 in chip seek to find
enhancers and what they did here is
basically take tissue from the limb for
the forebrain and from the midbrain did
ship with P 300 and they find about 2500
peaks in the genome that could be 2,100
peaks in the genome it could be in the
limb 2500 so in for brain 561 in the
midbrain and what they showed later is
that if for example if you think the
forebrain peak and check it in the mouse
si and we'll talk later on about
enhancer essays they this is definitely
a forebrain answer this one is a
mid-range enhancer and here you can see
an ice pick and a limb and it's
definitely a limb enhancer and they got
as I mentioned a really good success
rate compared to conservation and
going back to the first slide that I
showed you if you look at just
conservation usually what you get is
about a 50 percent success rate of the
sequence actually being an enhancer but
if you look in terms of just finding it
being a forebrain it's actually random
right you're looking at conservation but
you don't know what that sequence is
doing it could be in your brain gene and
you can think that it might be doing for
brain enhancer activity but you really
don't know while here the advantage of
chip is that you're starting with the
tissue that you're interested in right
so if you're starting with the limb and
doing chip on an antibody that finds you
enhancers you respected anything that
you're going to find a lot of limb
enhancers and so that's another
advantage of chip and if you look at
tissue specificity here in dark blue see
that 80% of your sequences tend to be
enhancers in the limb and not just
anywhere else and so it gives you very
good tissue specificity or here or so
forth is that clear for chip
okay so that's for enhancers and then of
course we mentioned silencers there's a
few marks that basically light up
silencers and probably the most used one
there is h3k27 trimethylation so similar
the h3k27 acetylation so if you have a
set elated lies in here you're usually
active if you have three methyl groups
on that same residue
you're usually silenced and so that is
usually a good mark for this but there
are other marks for silencing and of
course there's DNA methylation just
having the DNA being methylated here
usually suggests that things are
silenced in that region and then finally
we talked about insulators in mammals
there's not a lot of them found the best
one is ctcf which is a transcription
factor that binds to insulators but also
other things and just to show you again
the advantage of ctcf this is worked by
Bing wrens group and from a while ago
where they did Chip seek for CD CF to
find insulators what they show it also
is that insulators are pretty common and
among other tissue so looks like
enhancers or the main group that serves
changes between tissues and defines
tissue specificity insulators didn't
change much but going back to the logo
plot that I showed you this was sort of
the consensus that they had in the past
for ctcf but now that you get all these
tons of binding sites throughout the
genome you can see that you get a much
more refined logo plot and a much better
understanding of what it binds to sorry
so ctcf is a transcription factor that
is known to bind to specific sequences
and and work as an insulator it and so
it could be a good mark for insulators
however it has been shown also to bind
to other things but and currently for
mammalians it's probably the best mark
for insulators and an antibody for it in
the chip c could be used to find
insulators
any other questions on chip before we go
on okay so another commonly used and
methods are a DNS seek or a taxi and
they take advantage of basically open
chromatin regions so as I mentioned DNA
is wrapped up in nucleosomes but when
something is active for example if you
have here a promoter that's active this
region serve becomes open and free of
nucleosome regions as you can see here
or this enhancer right here can also be
opened open we have new clothes own
regions and so what you can do is take
advantage of DNS so and you can use DNS
and DNS will cut very well things that
don't have something right here and like
nucleosomes that serve and basically
folded DNA and make it harder for the
Dinos to cut and so things like this
that are active and will get cut much
easier than things here that are not
active and you can take advantage of
that of finding basically active regions
in the genome and so this is sort of a
slide that shows them the DNS seek kind
of a pipeline where you isolate cells or
nuclei that you're interested in and as
I mentioned there are things that are
open like here things that have
nucleosomes on and things that have
transcription factors binding to it and
so when you digest with Deanna's you get
these different fractions of things with
nucleosomes with transcription factors
for example they're binding or just open
regions and that you can fraction eight
by size and actually make a library
sequence and find all the open regions
in the genome suggesting that they could
be active now one thing to take in mind
it doesn't this mean that they're active
in the sense that they're promoters or
enhancers they could be active also
there's binding there or there's things
that go there that it could be
insulators or silencers also so DNS seek
basically gives you all the regions in
the genome that have some kind of
function you don't know the function of
what they're doing they could be
promoters enhancers transcribe genes and
so forth so what really is nice to do is
overlay Dinah's see
with your chip seek the advantage of
chip seek if we go all the way back here
is that you have all these things that
tell you what these sequences are doing
right silencers should have this so if
you have a DNS hypersensitive site and
you have chip seek for the same tissue
that has an h3k27 trimethylation you
would think that that thing is more of a
silencer if you have h3k27 insulation in
the DNA is mark you think that might be
more of an active enhancer or so forth
and so DNS seek is served and was used
by only a few it's a handful of labs
this technique is quite hard to do and
you really have to be good to do it but
recently and they're sort of being a
revolution in that sense with a
technique called attack seek so a taxi
basically takes advantage of transpose
zones so again if you have regions with
closed chromatin and regions with open
chromatin well you can take advantage of
is transpose ohms that can jump and tend
to jump into active regions and what's
nice about it else is you can put
Illumina primers on these transposons
and so you have things that jump with
Illumina sequencing primers into active
regions and then you just make a library
and sequence so it's probably one of the
easiest methods ever and William
Greenleaf was one of the people who
developed it in Stanford says and I'm
quoting him as so easy that even a P I
can do it and then it's really easy it
takes one day and you get results and
what's nice about it also is that and
you can do it with very little starting
material and so now even a few months
ago there's an article of doing at taxi
con single cells and so a it's really a
cool technique to do to use and we've
been doing it quite a lot now in the lab
and it's really really easy versus
dynastic which really was complex sort
of thing to do so and this has really
taken off in a lot of metal labs again
due to the ease and ability to do it on
small number of cells and so and attacks
you cuz being great so that's serve and
how hey how we can find them now we'll
move a bit more
quickly into how far away to look for
them and so and there are different ways
to look for how far away so a lot of
times let's say we're interested in this
gene right here and we know for example
that this gene leads to disease and but
we have a lot of families and we have no
mutations in the gene and that is known
to lead to their disease so we think
maybe it's regulatory elements that
could be causing this and as I mentioned
regulatory events could regulate insist
so on the same chromosomal position or
they can do in trance from another
chromosome but if we won't look for
regulatory elements insists there are a
few ways that you can do this one is
using synteny blocks and which is again
taking advantage of comparative genomics
which is a bit old but you can compare
for example human to Mouse and you can
see that this block remain conserved
between human and mouse suggesting that
these two regulatory islands probably
regulate this gene and this one probably
regulates something else you can go
further in evolution chicken frog and so
forth and generate what's called a
synteny blocks here and that shows yes
that these elements probably regulate
this gene and there was some kind of
selective pressure that gave these two
together because if you lose any one of
them this gene now leads to some kind of
a phenotype that might be under
selection clear in terms of send any
blocks so people have generated a lot of
these synteny blocks to give you a sense
of how far away you could look for
regulatory elements of your gene so if
I'm interested in this gene and I want
to find the regulatory and once around
them I probably only search in this
block to find regulatory elements that
might regulate it insists on the same
chromosome and this is just an example
of a Cynthia block which I won't worry
other things that people use is just
sometimes fix distance you have a gene
you go 50 KB away and look for
regulatory elements around it you go 100
KB away or you go to the next
neighboring gene left neighboring gene
and if you do that and a lot of times we
find enhancers and introns of a
neighboring gene so worth going all the
way after the left and right neighbor
but nowadays I mean the main way we sort
of go and look for assists regulatory
elements
is through topological domains which
I'll talk about a bit later on but
basically what what people have seen is
that DNA is divided into these domains
and that are conserved between tissues
and between species and basically you
have this region here where a lot of
things interact with one another but you
get much less interaction with this
other region here so if your gene for
example was in here I would look for sis
regulatory elements only all the way up
to here and up the way here but not past
this so the topological domain sir can
give you how far away to look for your
gene of interest versus regulatory
elements is this clear in terms of to
watch end of the maze okay so if
functional assays to test for their
function and so this is a lot of what we
do in the lab and so we talk we've asked
for there was a question before I'm
promoters and so for promoters basically
it's quite simple you take a reporter
gene like GFP or lac Z or so forth
stick in a sequence that you think is a
promoter and you can then stick it into
cell amounts of fish chicken so forth
and see where it turns on and if it
turns on where you think that gene is
expressed you can speculate that that
sequence is sufficient to turn on
promoter activity enhancers very similar
to this you have a reporter gene and
then you have what's called a minimal
promoters so minimal promoter is usually
like a light switch that doesn't work
unless it has an enhancer in front of it
so if you have an enhancer in front of
it that will flip that light switch and
that will turn on the reporter gene so
it's a promoter that technically
shouldn't work but only if it has an
enhancer in front of it that will turn
it on and again you stick it into
something and see if it turns on the
reporter gene and one for example
commonly used a minimal promoter in mice
is HSP 68 a heat shock promoter 68 and
so should only be turned on if you heat
chalk the animal which usually doesn't
happen and so that's a great minimal
promoter if you have an enhancer it
turns it on turns on
clear okay
and so how do we test for enhancers or
promoters so as I mentioned you can take
the promoter vector or the answer vector
you stick it for example into cells and
luciferase is probably the most commonly
used and reporter gene because it gives
you a quantitive measurement and you
have what's called a little manometer
that basically measures how much
luciferase you're getting from either a
promoter or an answer and for example
you have a sequence here
that's a promoter versus and you serve
your controls usually having this vector
without this sequence and so you can see
for example here this is probably a
promoter because you get high expression
with the sequence here and no expression
without that sequence here suggesting
that that's a promoter clear in terms of
this okay so the advantage of cell
culture is that it's quick it's easy
it's cheap and it's quantitive so with
luciferase you really get a quantitive
readout of how strong that an answer is
or how and strong that promoter is the
disadvantage is it's not in vivo it's
not the whole organism so you know as
cells especially differentiated cells
they're established cell lines are not
really you know a liver is not really
have g2 cell and so forth so it's could
be quite different and cultured cells as
I said yeah tend to lose their tissue
characteristics and there's a lot of
variability that we see with this
sometimes if I I make this vector and
then I run out of it and then I make
another vector I can get quite some
differences sometimes and results and so
forth so for us we look at it is sort of
a plus or minus but not something in the
middle and can tell you if something is
a very strong enhancer or very strong
promoter usually in the middle ground
it's a big gray sometimes and but that
being said it's a great way to get a
sense of something if it's an answer a
promoter as I said it's cheap quantitive
we can really scale it up and in our lab
and I'll talk about later on we've been
doing technologies where you can test
for example 100,000 sequences for
enhancer activity or 100,000 sequences
for promoter activity all in one
experiment and so it's really a great
way to
all of these things in terms of it on
the sequence level so there are some
differences though there are some things
that are very similar so the question is
yes I know and so in there there are
different types of promoters I didn't go
to in terms of time but there's
promoters of Tata box which you see more
in housekeeping genes there's Titleist
promoters also there's a whole sort of
like a whole lecture that could be given
on different types of promoters and and
and then but promoters also have there's
the core promoter and then there's the
I'm blanking on the definition and it's
so right next to the core promoter is
the sequences where you have a lot of
transcription factor binding sites which
could be very similar to enhancers and
actually people there's a few articles
if people will be using promoters to
find enhancers and so based on the
sequence of the transcription factor
binding sites of the promoter can we
find enhancers that look similar and do
they regulate so yeah so yeah a short
answer yes or no okay so another widely
used sa zebrafish
you can take the promoter the reporter
gene or and then hence remember Maury
reported gene tested in zebrafish
the advantage of zebrafish and and we do
quite a lot of zebrafish actually in our
lab is this quick it's cheap and you get
numerous embryos so from just one mating
usually get about a hundred embryos and
you can track fish over time so if
you're using a GFP and for example a
reporter gene you can look and see and
things over time and you don't like in
mice which I'll show in a minute you
have to take it out of the embryo so we
can follow for example an enhancer all
the way from development to adult and
see how it changes in terms of its
expression or so forth and this
advantage is that its distant to human
and a lot of times you get mosaicism and
you have to generate stable lines which
takes you quite a lot of time and just
like mice it takes about three months
for zebrafish to be mature and then you
can made it and generate a stable line
so it's great for development and doing
quick high-throughput things it's not
great if you really want to go more
later on
more - and again it's distant to human
but it has a lot of its advantages other
ways that people use is chicken
electroporation you can take these
sequences electric rate into a chicken
and then see where they light up
and again advantages it's quick and
cheap disadvantage it's only accessible
in the regions that you can actually
electro parade in the chicken usually
electroporation doesn't get into all the
cells so it's expressed in some cells so
you have variable expression and you
have to take out the embryos and look at
them and again distant to humans so
probably one of the more commonly used
ones is Mice and mice again you take
this sequence through make a transgenic
Mouse where you stick it into the one
cell embryo and then in this case you
take out the embryo disk and embryonic
day you live in an app so after 11 days
you take out the embryo stain it in this
case relaxi and here you see a very
strong limb enhancers suggesting that
this sequence of limb enhancers turned
on the memo from order turned on the
reporter gene so the advantage here
closer to humans it's a mammal DNA
usually integrates in one location and
so that gives you advantage the
disadvantage it's not that high
throughput it takes a lot of the time to
do these experiments and they're very
expensive for example and UCSF to do the
transgenic it cost me now about $3,000
so it's quite a lot of money and then
embryos or need to be taken out for each
time point so you can only look at that
time point that you're taking out the
embryo versus zebra fish for example
where you can just follow it over time
so that's also a disadvantage for mice
so all of this depends on basically what
you want to do and what you want to get
from your experiment and what's the
question you're asking and I think based
on that I think I would choose the
system to use based on its advantages
and disadvantages and in terms of mice
say there's a big project here in the
Berkeley Lab and down by a former lab
Eddie Rubin land Pinoccio and axel
diesel where they've characterized a lot
of enhancers using mice this is the URL
for this and you can check out and all
the sequences they tested they've tested
so far 2,300 sequences and about half of
them are enhancers and all of these are
online where you can go in and check if
you're interested in a certain gene you
can see if they characterize and in half
for this just to illustrate though how
not high-throughput this is this has
took them about 11 years to tech test
about 2317 sequences so it takes a lot
of time and if you multiply it times
about let's say $3,000 for each one
it's quite expensive also so again it's
not an high-throughput way but it's a
great way to really see where things are
expressed in a mammalian organism so
switching gears to silencers so as I
mentioned there are silencers and
there's a few silencers essays out there
there are not that great they work on
the idea that you have a reporter and in
this case a constitutive promoter so a
promoter that's always on that's very
strong and if you have something that's
a silencer you speculate that it will
turn off this very strong promoter and
that could be lead to turning off the
recorder gene expression or reducing it
another way to look for silencers just
like the other vector that I showed you
enhancer minimal promoter reporter gene
but you put a silencer here and again
does that reduce enhancer activity so
these two things are used usually for
silencers it's harder to see something
that gets turned off versus something
that gets turned on and that's one of
the reasons sort of enhancers are much
more easily easier to find and more sort
of looked at insulators same thing
minimal promoter reporter gene enhancer
and the thought is you have an insulator
here that will not let your enhancer
bind to this minimal promoter and turn
it on and then you're looking for
turning off gene expression clear so far
okay and then of course you can use this
in cell culture mice so forth and so on
so we've covered all of this and now
we're I'm gonna quickly go into since in
terms of time we're getting running
short regulation in 3d and then give you
one example it sort of ties everything
all up from the lab and so one very
important thing in one very take-home
message is that DNA is not served
they're sitting there in the nucleus and
so forth but it has various different
regions where you can sit and there's
various different interactions between
it and the interactions have been shown
to be very important in terms of gene
regulation and this is a nice picture
from a figure where you can see things
interact with one another both insists
and entrace and loop to one another and
answers can loop through promoters
silencers can loop through promoters and
so forth and so on so you really have to
think about VNA regulation and gene
regulation is sort of a three
dimensional kind of a plot and there's
been quite a few technologies now that
take advantage of this actually define
regulatory and regions and so for
example enhancers are known to bind to
promoters so if you have an enhancer
here in a promoter here in a region
where the enhancer is not active usually
you don't have binding but in the region
where it's active this enhancer loops
all the way to the promoter and you have
binding here and a loop so you can take
advantage of that and there's a
technology called 3c and it was the
first one that was invented and which
means confirmation and chromosome
confirmation capture so you have three
C's chromosome confirmation capture and
then later on derivatives of it are 4 C
5 C and high C's sort of whole genome 1
and I won't talk about all of them again
we're running low on time but just
briefly go through the idea of 3 C and
which everything else all of these
technologies are based on just you
understand the theory behind it so if
you have an enhancer the loops of the
promoter you get this loop and you get
now the enhancer right next to the
promoter so you can take advantage of
that by way of just like I mentioned
with chip you can use formaldehyde to
cross-linked the DNA binding proteins to
the DNA so you use that and now you have
the enhancer sitting right next to the
promoter due to having these binding
proteins you then cut the DNA either
with restriction enzymes or DNS I
Deanna's or other things and so now you
have these two loose ends that are cut
and then you do a ligation using very
dilute conditions and this is sort of
the key step where only things that are
in close proximity to one another will
ligate to one another so so if you're
like a ssin works you now have basically
your enhancer right next to your
promoter in terms of the DNA sequence
then you can reverse across links and
you can do either next-generation
sequencing or just a qPCR where you have
a primer from here
and a primer from here and that should
give you a product well let's say this
enhancer is one mega base away from the
promoter if you do a PCR on where they
don't interact and they don't loop you
know one mega base PCR will not work
it's just too far away rights for a PCR
to work so this PCR will give you
something this one will not give you
something and so that's something
measurable that you can quantify and see
if you get an interaction between these
two as I said there's methods where
people have developed like high C that
was commonly used where you can do this
in a whole genome sequencing if you want
to read more yeah this is a first
article about it and another method
that's being commonly used is chia pet
which is a bit more hard to do but the
advantage of chia pet is that you can
screen for specific interactions that
you want so if I go back here here this
will give me all the interactions in the
genome I'm just showing you the enhancer
and the promoter but there are other
interactions in the genome that are
happening with chia pet what you do is
you have an extra step that's similar to
chip where you use an antibody so let's
say I use an antibody that's specific
for promoters like RNA polymerase they
can pick up promoters so that way I can
get just the promoter interactions in
the genome and when I sequence them it
gives me a much better resolution where
I'm sort of selecting just for the
interactions that I'm interested in this
case the promoter interactions so chia
pet is basically a chip strung on to a
high C is that clear for everybody so
the advantage is the resolution when you
sequence high C you get you know now the
resolution is much better with
improvement of technologies but usually
get 5 to 10 KB resolution of
interactions so these are really big and
you don't know what's interacting with
what the chip at a servo filter to look
at the interactions that you're
interested in for example promoter
interactions so using high C going back
to the logical domains people have seen
that there's these domains where things
tend to interact a lot between one
another and then there is no there is
crosstalk but not as much between these
domains and then going back to how far
away you look for enhancer you can use
these domains and based on this and
these domains seem to be conserved
between different tissues different cell
types and different
mammalian organisms at least have been
shown and so you can use them again in
the question of how far away do you want
to look for an enhancer for your gene
you can look at what where is it the
topological domains and where the
boundaries for it another method to look
at interactions is a DNA fish and I'll
quickly go through this and this is just
an example of one of this and so here we
have a gene called sonic hedgehog and
mutations in this gene in humans in the
coding region need to hold a pro since F
allele in malformations a lot of bad
things and then 1 million base pairs
from sonic hedgehog is the sonic
hedgehog limb enhancer that turns this
gene on in the limb if you knock it out
in mice you get these limb truncation
phenotype that you can see here and this
is an enhancer not a gene and if you
sequence patients who have an extra
finger polydactyly they all have
mutations in this enhancer so one group
shiridi cheese group in in Japan
actually wanted to show that this an
answer actually interacts with sonic
hedgehog and turns it on one Megabass
away and so one way to do that was DNA
fish and the idea is that you can have a
probe here that is red that targets your
promoter of the gene here and you have
another probe here that targets your
enhancer that is green and if you look
at the limb and sonic hedgehog is
expressed right here this portion in the
limb if it interacts and you have
looping basically right here in the limb
and what you can see here is that this
is a region where sorry where it doesn't
interact and you can see there's you see
the red and the green are not close to
one another but in this region where it
does interact you can see that the red
and green are one on top of each other
suggesting that you have looping here to
interact but here four it doesn't
interact no looping clear for this
technique so it's basically taking
advantage of chromosomes and and sort of
cytogenetics old side of genetics to
show interactions versus non-interactive
so the last part I'll stop with the one
example from our lab this will be just a
few minutes to sort of put everything
together and this is
work by a very talented postdoc in my
lab Roman bierenbaum who now has his own
lab in Israel and he was really
interested in this disease called split
end and float malformation this is the
phenotype that you can see and we have
quite a lot of patients that we've
collected in the lab and split hand and
foot is thought to be it was mapped to
these regions these chromosomal regions
and he was specifically interested in
this one split on foot one which was
mapped to be near DL X 5 & 6 however a
lot of the patients did not have
mutations in the gene DL X 5 & 6 the
reason people think that DL X 5 & 6 are
the sort of the culprit genes is that
and when you take both of them are
expressed in the limb and when you knock
both of them out in mice this is what
you get the split hand and flip
phenotype so there's pretty good
evidence that and knocking out these
genes leads to this phenotype in
mutations in these genes lead to these
phenotypes and now there's actually two
mutations in DL X 5 that have been found
in patients that lead to deal X to split
hand & foot but most mutations actually
have and no mutations in these genes so
he really wanted to find the enhancers
for DL X 5 and 6 and so the way he did
this was look at there's a lot of
deletions and translocations and
patients and so for example all of these
deletions lead to split down and foot
all of these did not lead to split hand
and foot and there's some inversions and
translocations also and basically using
all of them I won't bore you for this II
found a region where we think the split
hand and foot enhancers could be and
here because of all these clinical
studies and so the next thing that we
did is did comparative genomics just
like I showed you before and look for
regions that are conserved all the way
in evolution that are near DL X 5 & 6 so
and the L X 5 & 6 are here and we're
looking at this critical region to find
things that could be enhancers that are
conserved for example this sequence
conserved all the way down to fish and
so we found about 29 sequences that are
conserved between human and frog and we
started testing them for enhancer
activity with enhancer sa that I just
showed you in zebrafish where we take
the sequence that is conserved throw it
in front of middle
reporter gene stick it into the fish and
see does it light up in the limb in this
case in the fin suggesting that it could
be a fin enhancer a limb enhancer that's
altered in that patient and we also did
this in mice same thing what I showed
you before so and this is the region DL
X 5 & 6 and you can see we are finding
enhancers but none of them are actually
in the limb so this one was a brain kill
arch this one was a year enhancer and
some patients here have actually hearing
loss and so forth and but we weren't
finding the limb enhancers for this so
luckily the time chip seek datasets came
out and the thing with comparative
genomics is that and one chip data set
that I showed you is this one for the
limb which we looked at and the thing
with comparative genomics is that you
usually think that things are conserved
like for example this exon or this exon
will probably be conserved in evolution
because it has a protein function and
that's why it's conserved not because it
has a regulatory function and so you
would throw it out of anything that you
would think is a regulatory element in
general but chips seek because it looks
with an antibody where you have things
that could have enhancer marks you serve
unbiased and so when we look for example
if this data set that I mentioned before
for limb Peaks we found two Peaks that
overlap these two exons that are coding
for protein but also have an enhancer
mark that suggests that it's enhancer so
again if i was using comparative
genomics i probably ignore it because
the conservation is probably coming from
protein and so you know sort of ignoring
the obvious like this sign that of this
guy that i see a lot when i come out of
the bart and so and if we look here when
we tested this in zebrafish this was
actually negative but this one was a
very nice fin enhancer and when we
tested in mice actually both of them
were very nice limb enhancers that are
also coding exons of this gene dining
and you can see here that they're very
similar in terms of the expression both
of them 2d lx5 to this gene that's 900
KB away from this so using chip seek and
sub comparative genomics we can find
these we could do these enhancer essays
and in the next step what we want
the show is that they interact so if I
go back here do these actually turn on
these jeans and so going back to the two
methods that I mentioned three see we
could do three C and C have a primer
here and a primer here and see do they
interact and when we do that this is in
the limb versus a tissue where there's
no interaction the heart you can see
that if we have a primer from here and a
primer from here we get much higher qPCR
results suggesting that they interact
and then going to the DNA fish that I
just showed you we can have a back probe
here and a probe here and if we look at
the limb versus the heart where they
don't interact we see much more
interaction between this probe in this
probe so the first thing that they loop
and interact and that's measurable you
can see how many times you see it in the
limb versus how many times you see it in
the heart and you can see that they
interact with one another another thing
we could do is look do chip which I also
mention to you and so you could do chip
to see what marks do you get for these
things versus these things and so you
can see if I do a chip for an enhancer
for this region you can see that it has
an enhancer mark in the limb and this is
in the limb tissue but if I do a chip
for the transcribe gene for a gene
that's active this gene is not active in
the limb as you can see here but this
gene DLX v and the elect six both of
them are very active in the limb and so
using chip I can show that this sequence
is in the limb probably our limb
enhancers and these are limb genes and
so we could suggest that that might
regulate these genes also so just to sum
up and that was sort of an example
putting everything together hopefully
wasn't too fast for you and really if
you want to think about gene regulation
this is for the metaphor I suggest using
where you have all these interactions in
the nucleus and things actually move
around connect disconnect and so forth
and with that I'll shut up and happy for
any other questions that you have